HOWIE:  AS THE BORDER CRISIS
INTENSIFIED, MORE PEOPLE ARE
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST PRESIDENT
BIDEN’S STANCE ON NOT ALLOWING
JOURNALISTS TO VISIT THE
OVERCROWDED TEXAS FACILITIES.
>> BLOCKING ACCESS TO THE NEWS
MEDIA IS NOT LEVELING WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
KEPT TALKING ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
WE’RE NOT GETTING TRANS TRANSPAR
WITH WHAT’S HAPPENING IN THE
BORDER.
HOWIE:  KRISTIN WALKER
CHALLENGED THE PRESIDENT AT THAT
FIRST NEWS CONFERENCE.
>> WILL YOU COMMIT TO ALLOWING
JOURNALISTS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE FACILITIES THAT ARE OVER
CROWDED MOVING FORWARD?
>> I WILL COMMIT WHEN MY PLAN
VERY SHORTLY IS UNDERWAY TO LET
YOU HAVE ACCESS TO NOT JUST THEM
BUT THE OTHER FACILITIES AS
WELL.
HOWIE:  THE PRESIDENT DIDN’T
AGREE TO A TIMETABLE, NEITHER
DID JEN PSAKI ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY
THIS MORNING.
I CAN’T REACH ANY OTHER
CONCLUSION OTHER THAN THE BIDEN
TEAM KNOWS THE MEDIA ARE HEAVILY
HE FOCUSED ON THE BORDER CRISIS
ANTAND DON’T WANT PICTURES THAT
WOULD FUEL ESPECIALLY THE
TELEVISION COVERAGE.
>> IT’S COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE.
IF THIS HAPPENED WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS OF THE PRESS, THE
EXPLOSION OF FURY WOULD BE
LOUDER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CREATED
THE CRISIS, THEY’RE SORT OF
DENYING THE CRISIS WHILE
BLOCKING ACCESS TO THE PRESS TO
DOCUMENT THE CRISIS FIRSTHAND.
THERE’S AN NBC NEWS REPORT THAT
THEY’RE NOT ALLOWING RIDE ALONG
FOR REPORTERS AT THE BORDER,
THEY’RE SAYING DIRECT QUESTIONS
TO WASHINGTON, DON’T TALK TO
JOURNALISTS DOWN THERE.
THEY’RE CALLING IT A GAG ORDER,
ON TOP OF THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
FACILITIES, THE KIDS IN CAGE AS
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD CALL THEM.
IT’S OUTRAGEOUS.
HOWIE:  LIZ, THE WHITE HOUSE DID
ALLOW NBC REPORTER GABE G
UTIERREZ TO GO TO AN HHS
FACILITY, A NICE ONE WITH A
SOCCER FIELD, NOT AS OVERCROWDED
BUT NOT BORDER PATROL FACILITIES
THAT ARE BADLY OVERCROWDED.
LET’S HEAR FROM HIS REPORT.
>> THE CHILDREN WE SAW TODAY
WERE CALM.
THEY SEEMED TO BE IN GOOD
SPIRITS.
BUT THIS ISSUE IS ABOUT MUCH
MORE THAN JUST THIS ONE HHS
FACILITY.
HOWIE:  HE KNEW WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
DO YOU THINK IT’S THE GROWING
MEDIA PRESSURE, THOUGH, THAT
KIND OF PROMPTED THE WHITE HOUSE
AT LEAST TO ALLOW ONE REPORTER
ACCESS TO ONE FACILITY?
>> WELL, YES, BUT IN AND OF
ITSELF, THAT’S RIDICULOUS.
GUY IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS SUPPOSED TO
TURN THE PAGE ON WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS HEAVILY CRITICIZED FOR
AND THAT WAS NO TRANSPARENCY.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
TRANSPARENT.
THE FIRST MOVE THEY MAKE IS TO
BE NONTRANSPARENT.
IT IS RIDICULOUS, OUTRAGEOUS AND
THIS IS STARTING TO GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION AND TRACTION WITH THE
MEDIA AND YOU CAN SEE WHETHER
IT’S NBC OR ABC WHERE SHE HAD
HER FACTS AND NUMBERS AND SHE
PUSHED HIM HARD AND AT ONE POINT
HE SAID IS THAT A REAL QUESTION.
WE’VE SEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
BRISTLE.
THEY DO THAT.
THE FACT IS, THE PRESS IS
PUSHING HARD AND THEY SHOULD.
BIDEN IS VERY, VERY VULNERABLE
TO CRITICISM HERE.
HOWIE:  THAT SEE  THEY INTERVIEW
9-YEAR-OLD BOY WHO WALKED FROM
HIS COUNTRY TO THE BORDER.
THAT WAS ONE STAND-OUT MOMENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CERTAINLY GOT
LOTS OF MORAL CONDEMNATION FROM
THE PRESS OVER HIS TREATMENT OF
MIGRANT FAMILIES, ESPECIALLY
SEPARATING FAMILIES BUT EVEN
KNOWING THEY WOULD GET BEAT UP
OVER IT, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID ALLOW
JOURNALISTS ACCESS TO THESE
FACILITIES.
>> YEAH.
THE TRANSPARENCY WAS MUCH BETTER
ACTUALLY DURING THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS FRONT.
AND I WOULD SAY THE FAMILY
SEPARATION POLICY WAS A DISASTER
POLITICALLY AND ON A
HUMANITARIAN BASIS BUT THAT WAS
SHORT LIVED.
A LOT OF THE FUTURE POLICIES
BEYOND THAT, THAT ACTUALLY
HELPED CLEAN UP THE MESS DOWN
THERE AND MITIGATE A LOT OF THE
STRUGGLE.
THOSE WERE SWEPT ASIDE BY TEAM
BIDEN, LEADING TO THE CURRENT
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE AND AGAIN,
THEY’RE ACTIVELY TRYING TO COVER
IT UP.
IT’S ASTONISHING THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS.
CAN YOU COMMIT TO TRANSPARENCY?
HE SAID, WELL, YES EVENTUALLY.
THEY SAID WHEN.
HE SAID I DON’T KNOW.
HOW IS THAT AN ACCEPTABLE
ANSWER.
OF COURSE IT’S NOT.
HOWIE:  AXIOS OBTAINED PICTURES
OF BORDER FACILITIES FROM --
THAT HAD BEEN LEAKED TO
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN HENRY
CUELLAR.
I THINK IT’S CLEAR THAT THE
MEDIA ARE GOING TO GET THE
IMAGES ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
THE WHITE HOUSE MUST KNOW IT’S
LOSING CONTROL OF THE NARRATIVE
ANT CONDITIONED JUST SAY THIS IS
JUST A SMALL PROBLEM THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH.
>> THEY LET GABE GO IN FROM NBC.
THEY BROUGHT HIM TO A MODEL --
HOWIE:  MODEL FACILITY, YES.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE WAS
HIGHLY CRITICAL OF THE PRESS BUT
THIS IS WHERE THE PRESS SHINES.
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
GET THAT SUNSHINE IN THERE,
BLAST IN THE LIGHT AND THE
CAMERAS AND THE ACTION AND YOU
SEE WHAT’S GOING ON AND THE
PRESS WILL FIND OUT AND THERE
SHOULD BE RESPECT FOR THEM AND
FOR ANYBODY WHO IS TRYING TO GET
IN THERE AND SEE THE TRUE STORY.
YOU CAN’T JUST SIT THERE AND SAY
I’LL LET YOU GUYS IN WHEN THE
OPTICS LOOK BETTER, WHERE WE CAN
CLEAN THINGS UP.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
AND THE PRESS NEEDS TO BE VERY,
VERY HARD AND PRESS AN CONTINUE
ON THAT WE HAVE A MOMENT OF
CONSENSUS, I THINK EVEN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA ARE UNITED THAT
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
GUY, LIZ, GREAT DISCUSSION.